hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one shot now I meant
to get to the sooner but we were busy
with the livestream and various other
things but I will do more regular
episodes of this maybe even daily
because I'm really intrigued by this I
just loaded up the game and then Niko
started talking to me he was like
calling out my name and he says he's
like kind of panic that I'm not
responding so I'm gonna find out what
Niko wants to say to me here are can you
hear me yeah yeah I can oh shoot what
happened
everything went pitch-black for a second
oh oh because I closed the game oh no ok
alright then love it super weird ok so
where we last left off is we just got
the iron bar which I should be able to
use to fold in the machine or something
to that effect like be able to pry
something out of something else oh yeah
something in the area hurts to breathe I
need a gas mask to be able to go any
farther north but as far as I know I've
reached the ends of the maps
besides whoa hello I were you hello
markiplier are you there
yes I am what happened if I say no no
I'm assuming this is a sarcastic
response Oh bummer wait you just
answered me you sure have a sense of
humor markiplier yeah me there's a robot
here attached to a boat it doesn't seem
that power and its joints arrested over
as well but I think we should be able to
fix it after all we'll need to cross
this ocean to get to the tower okay so
we need to find a way to fix that and I
shouldn't be so sarcastic - Niko that
seems mean I'm gonna try to be a bit
more serious about my response be
but then again I've been given a modicum
of power and I have no idea how to
handle that so I'm going to take this
iron bar that I got and I should be able
to use it on something here to give that
robot power because if that's my logic
here then that's an acceptable way to go
maybe this guy's got advice here login
no no more question
all right all thanks for the safe
travels oh wait what there in here there
was something over can I kind of use
this or something it's a Power Cell I
think oh the word profit bot is written
on the side didn't notice that earlier
oh so this is the power source for that
profit bot outside and then the other
character the red haired robot over in
the eastern area that was there Power
Cells for the both robots which is
really weird because it seems like the
other one is tamed and I don't know what
that means
weird something used to fit in there so
I can either put something in there or I
could put something in the robot or
maybe do a transitional thing here in
their box looks interesting I wish I had
something to pry it open with maybe I do
the screwdrivers not nearly big enough
to pry it open okay how about the metal
rod
the pipe won't fit in the cracks we'll
need to oh ok I know what I need to do
ok I'm smart and I have an idea of how
to Latin things with machinery I'm not
able to flatten the lightbulb yes I can
flatten someone else something else not
someone else I don't have any intention
to fly anybody especially Niko all right
flatten it uh-huh do you want me to
crush the pipe in earmark flyer whoo but
I don't wanna get too close
be brave that was scary
oh you did it oh good job Niko you were
so brave ok so now we got it well I
guess technically we got a crowbar now
so what do I do with this screwdriver oh
we don't have to use this again
markiplier well I don't know if we will
you might have to be brave a few more
times before we get to the end of this
adventure ok so if I have the
screwdriver what could that be used for
because if I need something big to pry
the Power Cell out of this one then I
don't know yeah I don't know what we're
gonna need it
in the long run this bar should open it
okay it's a little metal cube and some
broken glass in here looks like what
used to be a machine part it says solar
battery on the side ok well I got a
solar battery and maybe I'll be able to
charge it in the light of this thing so
if I take not that with the broken
battery a lot of small glowing shrimp
maybe if I put it in here the battery
sits in the slot perfectly looks like
we're on the right track but nothing
happened so there's got to be a way to
maybe if I combine this with the light
bulb ah feels like we're on the right
track though for this I don't think we
can do anything else but maybe I can
combine the screwdriver in that No
than that no maybe I could fill the
empty bottle with some shrimp from one
of the pools and then combine that okay
a little bit of loading lag there and
then combine that with what I need
because there's got to be a reason I
have the screwdriver I've been walking
around pretty much everywhere here and
the only things that I don't have or
means to power this power cell it fits
in that slot perfectly but what does
that mean because I can't interact with
these pools at all but there was
something about the notification saying
if you see a particularly bubbling pool
you were supposed to contact authorities
immediately because that could be a
source of power because I'm assuming
that those jars that are filled with the
phosphorescent like shrimp in there that
they're some sort of light which is the
only power source in this entire place
so there's got to be in one of these
pools here a particularly glowing or
bubbling piece of water and that would
mean that I'll be able to get some
shrimp from it unless I need a fishing
rod or something like that or wait and
see green glow in the distance wait
where did the row with the rowboat go
okay so he says I don't think this
battery is supposed to be for the robot
which means that this battery is for
that thing down below and if I were to
combine if I were combine this with a
Power Cell of some sort then I would be
able to power it that's my thought the
Sun will not return and the abyss is
calling my name I'm sorry everyone for
choosing to leave before the darkness
suffocates us all
I mean what would you do if you were
faced with like just knowing that the
world was going to end if nothing was
going to come to save it I guess it
would be pretty depressing in the long
run
but maybe maybe the person who is over
here knows something about what's going
on do we need further assistance I think
we do I think we might need it can you
help me with this okay I guess we're so
strong we know what we're gonna do top
it's covered with wire mesh can I take
one of these jars of glowing shrimp for
you you need them real badly can you
live without them all right all right so
there must be someplace that I use so I
got the screwdriver so the only place I
haven't gone is further to the east so
I'm gonna go over there and see if
there's something that I can use it on
wait okay all right then I saw you
heading towards this direction the mines
have been abandoned for a long time I
cannot guarantee that it's safe if you
must enter it it is my duty to accompany
you at least once oh thanks oh cool
let's go on the mines I guess together
alone what is that little gadget on the
ground kind of looks like a camera
what's left of a camera anyway probably
even part of a robot at one point
Oh or not I do not know all right I'll
take it then your your lack of knowledge
doesn't disturb me all right another one
of those shrimp jars but they're just
lying all around if those can be used
for power I wonder why they're just used
for light I can see a faint yellow glow
in the distance don't stand too close to
the edge oh sorry
looks like even the entrance tunnel
collapsed off without a vehicle we can't
proceed can we walk I can but for you
it's a safety violation I won't allow it
what the Hat anyway if the huge network
of underground mines the source of this
world's metal and non phosphor fuels
this is what propelled the world into be
industrial aged so now it's lost forever
it's been for a while now when the Sun
went out the man the mines were the
first to be abandoned amidst the initial
panic even the robots have all been
cleared out and repurposed and make
sense there was always one that insisted
on going back oh I hope he's okay so who
went back down in the mines why would
they go back down in the mines the
yellow light is gone now must've
imagined it so that might have been the
robot that's still down there do be
careful in here all right I will dry but
there's nothing else to be careful for I
don't have a vehicle and the tracks
still meet up with the cart ready to
leave I guess there's nothing here
besides that robot that's still working
down in the mines I mean I think if
that's even what it actually is
so is there nothing else here now that
was literally it that was just one more
step over into the right and then we got
a camera so there's got to be something
to be with this camera that we have like
what is that for
can't combine those I use the
screwdriver to pull the lens out okay
all righty then done yeah we got a lens
I don't know it's a large glass lens can
I combine that the lens pops right in
holy crap
all righty then so maybe that was all we
needed or maybe this we're using the Sun
directly on the battery I would have
never thought of that well I mean I
think you thought of that we were kind
of on the right track before but I don't
know why that's deserving now good
thinking markiplier thanks I think a lot
with my brain in my head at least I
think it's in my head I've never seen it
before
ok then looks like it's already fully
charged that was fast
well damn but I am the things go good so
now that I got that battery I can pop it
in the central system I guess mean just
walking around with this light bulb like
if it's supposed to be up in the tower I
imagine that it's somehow amplifies the
whole deal but just me walking around
with this light bulb must be like a
source of incredible power in the palm
of my hand which would be astonishing
just to carry around this world son and
then no one here that I've met yet is
trying to take it from me you know what
I mean because I don't know if it's all
robots around here I don't know if
that's the case it might just be that
the robots were made to serve a purpose
obviously and then they are quote
unquote aimed you know and them have
sentience I guess I mean the profit bot
is not tamed and obviously doesn't have
sending is good can make choices for
itself
but that other bot camped wandering
remembers name now silver a rectangle
shaped whole yep so we put the charge
battery so if the charge battery does
something mom oh [ __ ] whoa what do they
do
I mean that's a lot for one single
battery wall
it's charge everything I am functional
did you power the generator I guess we
did right markiplier hell yeah we did
you know we did hello I am functional I
can walk
ah good for you I'm happy to help I
guess uh-huh celebrate it for a while -
the power runs out I guess
well I see you've made progress in the
world that progress stops here I believe
you need a code to unlock a certain box
well the code no longer exists in this
world oh no you don't or don't know
that's bad I do yeah I do good start
looking where should I look where would
i look oh no not there okay start
looking great so now it's somewhere in
my computer where the heck would that be
I don't know I don't know where would it
be behind the screen no dream ah I know
how to do it I'll sort by the date
modified to the most recent one well
there it is there it is oh boy oh boy oh
boy what is that whoa okay alright then
does your daughter just joy your joy ah
this does is it doesn't to tell you I've
message to you and I'm afraid I must
make it brief I have left you a journal
part of which is written in a language
that are you dodge the Dodgers Dodgers
are you eat it and you will know what to
do I have also other doors it does it
doesn't owe you the code you need is two
nine eight five seven eight okay so I
know that some thugs put that over here
and put that over there to nine eight
five seven eight I got it I got all that
I think okay so now that I have that
good nine eight five seven eight got it
I think this is all going so well for me
I don't feel like my privacy have been
invaded at all all right it's so cool
though that is eyes cool so I'm guessing
that only powers the bat the the robots
in that room it didn't power everything
else so the robot that's in the Robo the
Robo got the rope the robot I guess the
bro ro w baat is empowered in because
there needs to be something else for
that
so then that told me that the code is to
the safe so I guess that's my only
alternative right now I have to go open
that safe and see what's inside I have
this bad habit why I didn't find that
camera in the last one I have this bad
habit of being apprehensive to continue
on before I found everything especially
if it's something that I'm actually very
very interesting interested in seeing
absolutely everything oh man
block with a six digit code I remember
seeing a code man
it's weird because like this is for Nico
this has got to be bizarre like for Nico
like he's just trusting that I know
everything and yet in his mind I could
be setting up everything just to mess
with him Wow it worked
wait how did you know the code I still
don't remember seeing one had some help
I have my ways I am a mysterious being
ah if I suggest that I had some help
that might tell Nico that there's others
like me I guess I mean I'm an honest guy
I had some help really from who yep
don't worry about it well now he's just
curious
okay maybe what's gonna save me go
alright let's see ah it's not a gas mask
also there's this weird looking book I
can't read it though but I can't read or
anything because I can I just don't know
what languages
is it French tell me it's French maybe
German Korean maybe alright so what do
we got it would hi hello what is that I
don't know I don't know what that is I'd
like to know what that is but I don't
know that in that's gonna feel popped up
in these documents no okay
alright then guess we're just gonna
ignore that so if we put on the gas mask
oh we're gonna have to okay what about
the strange journal Simon the Barons
it's written in an unknown language
all right here and I guess just gonna
walk past the weird glitch thing over
there not gonna worry about that at all
okay but if I go up here I know this is
where the gas mask was needed I should
be fine with the mask on oh you look so
scary - and so why is it all gashes here
the gas vent but what type of gas why
would there just be gas shooting up out
of the ground here
it could be from the phosphorus out
Avalon problems hello person welcome to
the old chemical processing plant most
of the equipment has already been well
relocated alrighty then Thank You mr.
robot we have here two pair of rubber
gloves they're a bit heavy
oh no you weak baby yarns hello person
robot assembly and repair services have
been discontinued at the baron's if you
have further inquiry please contact the
head engineer alright then
who is that seems to be a page ripped
out of a book cannot overstate the
importance of cleaning solvents in this
environment here's a simple recipe using
the alternative method discussing in the
last chapter utilizing the natural
properties of blue phosphor reagents
acidic gas blues phosphor rare form in a
well ventilated area direct the gas into
the container of your choice seal
immediately well maybe that's all of the
steps but I have a funny feeling that
there's something missing to that so
something about rare blue phosphor and
then gas which I'm sure there's an
abundance of around here so weird though
why is there just gas everywhere all
right I call that page I'm gonna go back
for just you know okay I'm gonna go
backwards just just I want to make sure
you know I just want to make sure
there's nothing else of extreme value
before I get that there's something
weird about the robots who get sent to
work near the gas fields they appear to
accumulate rust with a much slower rate
than others a few who work directly with
gas harvesting look practically new is
that a result of the atmosphere or am I
just seeing things I imagine if you're
an engineer you wouldn't just be seeing
things you'd know whether a robot is
rusted or not
that must be either a teller hey big guy
oh hello what are you doing here a
living person such as yourself should
have evacuated this place long ago would
know but I just got here
this world I mean see I have a son
Oh the Messiah I do not know what to say
greetings greeting you was not part of
my program even though I just tried to
do last have you spoken to prophet boss
I think so yeah
prophet vault was built with the sole
purpose of greeting you really yes he
cannot speak with anyone else at least
not with ease oh that's kind of sad
three Bell for that my purpose is to
guard this settlement even though the
residents have long gone I must remain
odd why don't I have not been tamed
tamed it was not worth the effort oh
that's good
because that too why why what is the
painting process and what does it mean
for these robot here like what does that
include
by the way some robots may start
following you around this settlement as
well
Oh hallo okay hi will weird do not be
alarmed it is their job to keep people
safe
unit RM two eight eight three four one
seven reporting for duty
Sully spoke with guardian of the
settlement I will now ask for you until
you reach your dormitory Oh what okay
thank you
two eight eight I'm gonna call you that
because that's all the numbers that I
remember here what do we have here looks
like they're evacuating the few tame
robots we have here sorry
just add up mental fart in the middle of
that make sense no point in keeping them
in the Barrens if all the people are
already gone I wonder if the engineer is
going to apparently phase one of the
evacuation ended prematurely big ship
started malfunctioning only after a few
round trips they said it was due to
something with squares I'm not sure what
they mean by that bummer
looks like they won't be able to
transport most of these surplus BOTS to
the city at this rate we were so hard on
them
I suppose the robots oh they are robots
did I make that up or did I already read
that I don't know our busy enough with
transporting people as it is I think
it's going to be our turn soon ma'am
some sort of crazy evacuation looking a
little dim their power still I think is
riding on this once a guardian of
residential areas so that's powering the
big robot but he seems to be running out
of a bit of power whoo Hidy Hidy Hidy ho
that's a lot of holes okay
can I go up there
I guess not I'm scared of ladders Nico
come on
you're scared of smashy things you're
scared of falling from incredible
Heights and dying Jade Louise some of
the ink on this page is faded likely due
to some sort of electrical or magnetic
interference I'm afraid this operation
can no longer be sustained the service
continued to fail so much that
maintenance cannot keep up the pace
fortunately it does not seem to be
happening to the robots at least not at
a significant rate time will tell so all
that's why all the computer systems are
broken they're just falling apart
checking checking terminal does not
respond this is a problem in dd-do it is
keep checking I suppose all of these
terminals do not boot also they are
cracked and are full of holes I am not
sure what to do now
I suppose keep checking it's weird
because they're they're not tamed so to
speak but they seem to have some sort of
understanding of the world and are not
sure what to do so their programming
might be more suggestions just like the
profit bot can't speak to anybody else
with ease you know I've never been
around so many robots before markiplier
or any robust at all I mean I see them
in cartoons and stuff but I've never
seen one in person they're pretty neat
don't you think Haney go do a robot
voices well that does mean dance for me
monkey dance yeah yeah well maybe I
should have seen the robot voice oh
hello hi there hello hi what are you
doing up there
I'm stationed here myself yes okay huh
maybe I could talk to him hello okay
don't say Xenia thanks for visiting me
again no one's ever visited me twice you
are so nice
is this a non-stop row of just various
robot dormitories okay sweetie six more
weeks until you can come home about time
huh gosh I can't imagine living in that
awful capsule wall dorm thing but guess
what soon you'll get to sleep in a real
bed and eat real food again right back
soon
love mom aww oh no these aren't robot
dorms these are holes in the wall that
people slept in
looks like we're supposed to pack stuff
for the evacuation starting today I wish
these books weren't so heavy gonna be a
pain to carry them onto the ship but
they're by the author I can't just throw
them away
the authored question mark who is the
author I have no idea I can't imagine
living in just a big-ass slew of holes
in the wall I guess you know in the end
you only really need to sleep so long as
it's moderately comfortable I guess it
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
but even so that's like kind of horrible
oh the other gas mask area was there
anything other there that I needed I
don't think so so eventually I need to
cycle back and and what oh did I get any
other items I guess I got rubber gloves
but I guess that's only to be able to do
like the the instructions that it was
giving me oh hello
this van is on the ground all the others
are taller so I could probably use this
vent initially the amount of noxious
fumes emitted by the natural gas vents
caught our team off-guard thank goodness
the medical team reacted as quickly as
it did despite its failure the first
expedition did bring up some interesting
observations about the Barrens we found
that there's not one but two such vent
zones with fumes being pumped out at
such high concentration it seems a
miracle the gas hasn't spread anywhere
else our biologists including conclude
that the phosphorus shrimp in the crater
pools were actively consuming the gas
the shrimp in the ocean also prevents
the gas from wafting off into the Glen
that's case and we owe a lot to these
little guys that's not to scoop them up
and then stuff them into jars maybe I
could capture some of this in the bottom
I guess you want me to fill the bottle
with the gas
yes that ought to do it okay so I got a
bottle of smoke so I have that I guess
that's good so what do we do with that
because there's tons of gas vents around
here but that's the only one that's
accessible to me and I'm imagining that
has to do with the combination that they
were talking about so that I can make
some sort of thing that I don't
understand what is hello bottle response
your looks different the water looks
like jelly from the bubble over the
surface well what do I do with that do I
introduce this smoke do it fill the
bottle with this stuff all right okay
okay cool but that means the smoke
escape so maybe that's like the second
step yep
dugu be defending the bottle opening
sighs one time years ago when I tried to
put tomato chowder in a baby bottle why
did you try to put tomato chowder in a
baby bottle
oh the grown-ups I was weird Oh do you
have a baby like brother or sister oh
they tell you how to use funnels and
then they also tell me I shouldn't try
to babysit when I'm old until I'm older
anyway which probably look for a funnel
or something okay
all right so I need a funnel to do that
hello what are you doing online yourself
the sky is dark that it is do you know
when the Sun will be back up we're
working on it
I've got the Sun in my hands right now
please don't freak out or anything but
I'm kind of a big deal I'm uh I'm the
Messiah and I talked to a God on a
regular basis I know I know it's
probably flow in your mind right now but
don't worry about it perfectly normal
for someone who lives an interesting and
amazing life such as me but I guess you
wouldn't understand anything about that
being a robot
okay so I decided back to where I was so
if I imagine that I have to do anything
else it has to be in that other gas vent
or to the east of that other gas zone
because I don't know if I went fully
that direction yet so I'll be right back
unit on ki 38470 ones born 30 mg already
been assigned an escort unit RM two
eight eight three four one seven if you
like me to leave you follow me if you
want understood I will now escort you
until you reach your dormitory okay
thank you I don't know which one's mine
I don't think any of these are mine what
is that infirmary
okay all right then hello organic person
who is alive the infirmary is up ahead
in case you need it for your organic
fleshy organs the things with which we
do hello person of organic makeup
welcome to the infirmary scanning for
injuries uh and complete injuries
detected none treatment required none
you are good to go
thank you okay so if I ever get injured
I come down here it's Abbas medical
fuels most of broken or rusted plastics
rim seems to be okay maybe I could use
that to put this stuff in the bottle
hello person are you seeking admission
to the infirmary Oh carry on then thank
you bye you were so helpful so matey
this needle is particularly long I
should be able to technically can't
combine those but I don't want to go
back just yet until I found absolutely
everything but it might be something
worth trying out because I well then
again I don't know I know it may be I
don't know how small these shrimp are if
they're going to be actually sucked up
into a syringe wait okay the board
seemed to be loose though I should be
able to pull them off with the right
tool I have a crowbar good thing I kept
this grub are a good technique oh I
suggested it to you as your Overlord
what a workout I know Nikko physical
labor whew that's a little disturbing a
bunch of robots without power I guess
the generator can only do so much man
it's amazing but just a slight dab of
the Sun on a battery and all these
things get power a big metal box with
complicated machinery robot looks rusty
complicated
January alright without breaking the
seal inject the liquid phosphor into the
container shake vigorously to engender
reaction use as soon as possible
inject so I do need to put the smoke in
first keep it sealed and then use the
syringe to get it in there and then
shake hand protection is critical after
the step resulting acid is moderately
stronger than common household with
cleaners I don't know what half these
words mean it's a good thing you're here
our Gabbar yeah I know I know what those
mean cleaning sponges the rough surface
okay alright I got that I don't think
there's anything else in here so I can
move on maybe I could use the cleaning
sponge on the big robot and give them a
good old scrub he seems to be a little
worse for wear these days so it's
possible that maybe he'd appreciate it
maybe it's just a nice thing to do maybe
it's not essential to the story but
maybe you know maybe it wouldn't be a
bad idea yeah yeah let me let me give
you a good look good low loss grub babe
alrighty then so nice you're so nice to
me
nope that's not it all right I'll be
right back I know what I need to do now
bottle on that yep fill it up open a
book and seal it off okay so you got a
bottle of smoke with hopefully a good
seal on that and don't pull that cork
off whatever you do we're gonna suck up
some phosphor rim and then we're gonna
do our deed here laughs so we're filling
the syringe I guess it's kind of like a
funnel the liquid might be too thick to
thin the needle try it actually went in
yes you need to believe and trust me
gross I agree but anyway let's see ah
now we just combined this bottle of
smoke I should inject the liquid through
the court right it's like I'm a doctor
so now you have oh I should probably
shake this too that's what the
instruction said it changed color I have
a bottle of acid now good what do I do
with that why do I need a bottle of acid
I'm supposed to use it like right away
but I don't know where to go for that
there's got to be something that's
rusted over that needs to be utilized
maybe the robot the robot maybe need
this hey buddy hey buddy boo you wanna
you want to be doused in acid oh I am
functional up with a unification
generator
yeah martyr bar helped me but yeah come
on nice to meet you I am robot 3:10
would you like me to take you somewhere
are you okay I cannot move well you're
still really rusty that is true
hold on markiplier and I will find a way
to help you what about this oh oh I
guessing you want me to pour this acid
on the spud yes my rampant attempts to
combine absolutely everything exactly
what I wanted to do dipping a big long
I hope this works I got a wet sponge and
no more acid cool all right hold still I
have no other choice
ha ha ha there man
I can move again thank you
I'm able to fulfill my purpose again
where would you like to go can you take
me to the tower
calculating closest destination to the
tower is the Glen port number my
built-in navigation circuits a pride I'm
gonna assume that's not good it is not
good at all
once again I cannot follow my
programming Oh is there anything I can
do to help in the event of an error you
should speak with the head engineer she
will know what to do the head engineer
she will know what to do talking about
silver Joe are you talking about silver
you talking about this they might be
talking about silver there but
unfortunately I do not have any more
timing this episode to pursue that so
I'm gonna put Nico to bed before I
actually close out the game here so I'm
not sleepy anymore well I don't know
what to do when you have to talk about
that cuz I need to go I guess but either
way thank you everybody so much for
watching hopefully Nico doesn't mind
being shunted into the darkness close
game but hopefully you guys are enjoying
this I will get two more episodes of
this very soon thank you so much for
watching let me know what you think of
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]